thank you guys we are indeed with a 2022
u.s junior chess champion
congratulations christopher what a
performance your initial feelings after
uh this clinch of the title
i almost can't describe it
i don't think i've ever won a tournament
as big as this before
absolutely you came into this event with
what ambitions
christopher just to play good chess
and see what happens i definitely didn't
expect to
win with this score or even or win it
let's say
well uh at what point in the tournament
did you feel like you're starting to
dream about a potential victory
maybe
right before the rest day when i was
leading the tournament by a point i
started to think about it
but the main focus was just on making
good moves and not too much the final
result and that is definitely a
champion's uh mindset now
in the last round against carissa with
the black pieces you know that the draw
is sufficient what was the strategy and
what were your
thoughts before the game started
i knew that it would be pretty hard to
force a draw because of the 30 move
rules so i just decided to play normally
and not in particular play for a draw
absolutely now take us through today's
game because
in fact at some point it felt at least
from an objective point of view that you
were in some danger did you feel that
way at any point
i did but i also saw that i was winning
at some point absolutely you are
definitely winning at some point
when she went ballistic with this bishop
takes f7 but this was the moment so
let's keep going a few more moves
you guys exchanged on e3
knight to e7 was indeed the right by the
way when did your preparation finish in
this game
um
i i think it finished at like
bishop e7 or something
perfect okay okay so quite far back all
right bishop take c3 rook take c3 and
now you took on e5
did you spot this idea of rook to d3
knight to d6 and the knight to g5
i did not spot this idea
and after castle queen to h5 taking
advantage of the fact that you're all
tied down
did you feel or did you speak with her
after the game
did she mention this move at all or uh
you don't know
i didn't speak to her after the game
absolutely so
rook to d3 might have been an
opportunity missed but she went for this
queen to eat when she was thinking for a
very long time at this point after
knight c5 came on the board almost
immediately she sacrificed the bishop
were you shocked because because we were
here on the panel we were looking at
bishop to c2 and all sorts of like
normal moves and then she blasted bishop
takes f7 on the board
i was definitely shocked
i definitely i didn't i definitely
didn't think there was enough
compensation for this piece sacrifice
and the engine asks pretty much
everybody didn't believe karissa um
knight to d5 that was a very good move
centralizing the piece opening up the
action of the queen as well c4
now
at this point instead of h6 did you
consider a move knight to f4
i did
i think i
was concerned about queen e3
queen to e3 and knight to d3 knight c to
d3
now we're getting some wild stuff
happening on the board well the position
is wild
yeah
in in and of itself so
but you decided to go h6
now at some point it it felt like the
trend is starting to buck a little bit
and you're on the defensive uh queen to
d6 knight to f3 yes bishop d5 was indeed
the right move but let's keep going with
queen to d6 and now you play the move g4
and she started thinking she had a lot
of options
what was the option that you were mostly
worried about
i think what she played actually knight
g5 knight g5 and what about knight to d4
this was the move that we were
considering and we were very worried
about your position right now
maybe g6 is possible just try to stop
knight f5
g6 yeah and uh
queen takes g4 you weren't worried at
all about the king getting a bit too
exposed or
maybe queen g4 i was definitely a bit
worried but i did think i should be able
to defend with good play
absolutely absolutely and she played the
move knight to g5 i really want to
commend this move uh and first of all
the calculation that went on with this
uh
queen sacrifice potential queen
sacrifice with this bishop to d5 of
course if she does take the queen there
is a checkmate this move worked to h6 i
really like this move uh by uh you and
we were starting to be a bit worried
about your position but when you played
this mover to h6 we really liked your
uh your process now
and after that i don't think you had any
problems did you feel like you have any
problems after this no absolutely not
christopher
big victory for you
you are the u.s junior champion not only
that
you're gaining quite a substantial uh
price but you're also punching a ticket
to the u.s championships coming up in
october how does that feel
amazing
what are your plans about that
championship about facing fabiano
caruana wesley saw and all the
superstars of american chess
i really don't have anything to lose so
i'll just
come into the games with
just try to be prepared and play good
chess
absolutely well you will definitely do
that and we cannot wait to see you at
the us chess championships once again
big congratulations christopher you are
the 2022 u.s junior champion
congratulations and our congratulations
to christopher very very very nicely
done 12 000 10 000. he goes to the world
junior
he goes to the u.s uh championships
world junior oh
absolutely absolutely where is this
going to be held